[موسيقى]
تحيه لكم اعزائي المشاهدين هذه نشره
التاسعه هذا المساء اليكم العناوين
لتحقيق نصر غائب منذ سته اشهر روسيا تضيق
الخناقه على بخمه وكيف ترد باستهداف القرم
بالمسيرات
جيل جديد باعداد كبيره ينشا في خيم
الدواعش في الهول
في جوله حصريه كاميرا العربيه في مخيم
الهول وهناك ارث داعش العائلي والفكريه
تنامى عبر اشبال التنظيم
في ايران تجدد ظاهره التصميم العمد
لطالبات المدارس والسلطات تلقي باللوم على
عدو خارجي مجهول
الضغوط الامريكيه على تيك توك تزداد مجلس
النواب يمنح الرئيس بايدن الحق في حظر
التطبيق الصيني
[موسيقى]
تفاصيل التاسعه تبدا من البقعه لاسخن في
العالم الان حيث الحرب في اوكرانيا تدخل
اياما جديده بعد العام الثاني المعارك
مشاهدينا تحتدم على الجبهات الشرقيه
تحديدا بمحيط باخموت ولا يقل الامر سخونه
هجوم مضاد في الجنوب والشرق وهو ما تدفع
نحوه القوه الحليفه في الغرب الذي يسعى
لدعم كييف بشتى الوسائل اخر مراحل الدعم
كانت الدبابات واليوم تدرس جديا ارسال
المقاتلات وفقا لوزير الدفاع الفرنسي
اذا مشاهدينا في اوكرانيا والجبهه الشرقيه
والتطورات الميدانيه هناك ما تزال القوات
الروسيه تسعى جاهده للسيطره على كامل
دنيتك لاحكام سيطرتها على كامل اقليم نشرح
قليلا هذه التطورات الميدانيه مشاهدينا من
خلال هذه الشاشه التفاعليه اذا مشاهدينا
نبدا في المتابعه اذا هنا في شرق اوكرانيا
ما الذي حصل اليوم التطورات اللافته هنا
في باخموت دعونا نذهب اليها اذا هنا باخمت
اذا مشاهدينا كثفت القوات الروسيه بمسانده
مجموعه هجماتها على الجبهه الشرقيه وكذلك
الشماليه
والجنوبيه كذلك في محاوله للسيطره على
كامل ضخمه وهي بذلك استخدمت اذن الجنود في
محاوله لحصار باخمت بشكل كامل على هذه
المدينه القوات الاوكرانيه لم تصمت هي
تحاول استخدام مجموعه من الدعم العسكري من
هنا من هذه المدينه مدينه شاذوف يار وهذا
عن طريق استخدام جنود كذلك ومجموعه كذلك
من الدبابات من اجل صد هجوم قوات فاجنر
والقوات الروسيه التي تحاول السيطره على
اذا هذا في ضخمه نذهب الى جبله جبهه اخرى
مشتعله اليوم هنا في الجنوب نتحدث عن شبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان اوكرانيا جنت
اليوم هجوما كبيرا بطائرات مسيره
اذا هذه هي الطائرات المسيره حوالي 10
طائرات مسيره نفذت هجمات مختلفه على مناطق
القرمو تمكنت القوات الروسيه من صد هذه
الهجمات واضافت انه لا اضرار او خسائر
كذلك في هذه الهجمات اذا التي شنتها
القوات الاوكرانيه باستخدام المسيرات
اذا مشاهدينا هذا كانت اهم التطورات
الميدانيه على هذه الخارطه سنتابع بعد
قليل المزيد حول ما الت اليه هذه التطورات
مع مراسلين في كييف وموسكو
على بعد اميال من الكريملين تسود حاله من
التاهب القصوى اثر تغيرات في مشهد الحرب
مع اوكرانيا مشاهد تحول فيها المهاجم الى
مدافع متاهب
موجه من الطائرات المسيره وضعت روسيا في
حاله تاهب قصوى بعد ان وصل بعضها تخوم
العاصمه موسكو امر دفع اعلى السلطات
لتشييد الرقابه على الحدود ومراقبه الحركه
الجويه
وفقا لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان القوات
الاوكرانيه حاولت مهاجمه مواقع للبنيه
التحتيه المدنيه في عدد من المناطق الهجوم
استهدف اربع مناطق على الاقل كان ابرزها
اقليم كرسندار على الجانب الاخر من بحر
ازوف في حين نجحت مسيره بالوصول الى محطه
غاز تابعه لشركه غاز بروم قرب مدينه
كولومنا الواقعه على بعد نحو 60 ميلا جنوب
شرق موسكو امر يعتبر سابقه في الحرب التي
بدات عامها الثاني الاستهداف اجبر موسكو
على رفع مستوى مراقبه الحدود واغلاق
المجال الجوي لمطار سام بطرسبورغ مؤقتا
وابعاد الرحلات الجويه وتاخير اخرى الكريم
بالوقوف وراء الهجوم لترد الاخيره بالنفي
على لسان ميخائيل بودولياك مستشار رئيس
مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
اوكرانيا لا تضرب اراضي روسيا الاتحاديه
اوكرانيا تخوض حربا دفاعيه بهدف نزع
احتلال كل اراضيها
في نهايه فبراير العام الفائت اتهمت موسكو
كيف باستهداف بيلكو
الروسيه المتاخمه للحدود واليوم تتجدد
المشاهد والاتهامات نفسها لكنها اكثر عمقا
وقربا من تخوم الكرملين
هذا واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ارسالها مذكره رسميه للولايات المتحده
لاشعارها بتعليق معاهده الحد من انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه المعروفه باسم ستارت واكد
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
لن تتراجع عن تعليق المشاركه في المعاهده
قبل تغير موقف واشنطن من اوكرانيا واوضح
ان موسكو تناقشه مع واشنطن معاهده ستارت
عبر قنوات مغلقه مشيرا الى ان روسيا
مستعده لتبادل المعلومات مع امريكا ولكن
عبر معاهده ستارت جديده
وفيما يتعلق بقضيه الحبوب قال وزير
الخارجيه الروسيس تمديد اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود مرهون بمراعاه
مصالح موسكو جاء ذلك خلال لقائه نظيره
التركي
انقره والامم المتحده توسطتها في التمديد
السابق لاتفاق تصدير الحبوب بين موسكو
وكيف فيما طلبت اوكرانيا من تركيا والامم
المتحده بدء مفاوضات تمديد اتفاق الحبوب
في المواقف الغربيه قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
تحتاج الى السلام بشكل ضروري اكثر من اي
حد او من اي احد نظرا للوضع الانساني الذي
تمر به وخلال مؤتمر صحفيين في اوزباكستان
حمل بلينكن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
مسؤوليه انهاء الحرب والدخول في مفاوضات
سلام جرح
لا احد يريد السلام بشكل عاجل بقدر ما
يحتاجه الاوكرانيون هناك ضحايا في كل يوم
بسبب العدوان الروسي الان نحن جميعا نعلم
الحقيقه ببساطه بان الحرب يمكن ان تنتهي
غدا او اليوم اذا اراد الرئيس بوتين اتخاذ
هذا القرار هو الذي بدا الحرب ويمكن ان
يقوم بانهائها
اما فيما يتعلق بمبادره الصين لاحلال
السلام في اوكرانيا قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الى الصين يجب ان تحدد دورها
كوسيط وليس كطرف يغذي الحرب من جانب روسيا
الصين لديها طريقان تسير من خلالهما فهي
تضع نفسها خارج الحسابات وتقدم نفسها كقوه
قادره على طرح السلام العالمي امام الراي
العام وفي الوقت ذاته تغذي الحرب التي
بدات روسيا وتشعل نيرانها
كما ذكرت قبل قليل في الشرح التفاعلي
للميدانيات الاوكرانيه تطورات لافته اليوم
في باخمت وفي القرن نتابع التفاصيل مع
مراسلينا منوسكو حذيفه طعمه مرحبا بكما
حذيفه ابدا معك كان هناك تاويل ربما شكل
لبسا من مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني عن ربما
القوات الاوكرانيه كانت ستنسحب من باخمت
ما حقيقه الموقف وضع القوات الاوكرانيه
هناك
حذيفه
حذيفه صوتك لا يصلني للاسف نعم ساعود اليك
ربما كاتيا طعمي اسالك كذلك عن تطور
الموقف في ماذا تقول
قوات الروسيه التي على ما يبدو انها تحرز
بعض التقدم هناك في ضخمه
مرحبا صهيب تصريحات الاخيره للقوات
الانفصاليه في دونيت كانت قد تحدثت عن
تقدم طبعا في المعارك في
المحيطه بباخموت طبعا كان هناك سيطر على
عده مناطق متاخمه لبخمت بالاضافه لذلك انا
قد تحدث رئيس الانفصالين في
محاوله لتطويق المدينه من الشمال والجنوب
لمنع وصول الامدادات الى القوات
الاوكرانيه ولكن من جانب اخر هناك كانت
تصريح لافت اليوم لرئيس قوات الخاصه الذي
تحدث عن ان المعارك هناك محتجمه وان الوضع
صعب جدا في بخموت بسبب ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تظهر مقاومه كبيره في هذه
المعركه وبسبب
توافد القوات الاوكرانيه باستمرار وعدم
انقطاع وصول القوات الاوكرانيه والامدادات
الى المدينه صهيب حذيفه هل تسمعني الان
نعم حذيفه كنت سالتك عن تصريح مستشار رئيس
زيلينسكي فهم منه بشكل او باخر على انه
القوات الاوكرانيه ربما تنسحب من باخمت
امام الضغط قوات فاجنر بالتحديد ما حقيقه
الموقف
نعم تحياتي صهيب في الحقيقه هذا الكسندر
روجانسكي وهو مستشار الرئيس الفلاديمير
زيليسكي الذي اجاب عن بعض اسئله الصحفيين
لصالح قناه سي ان ان وكان السؤال عن ما
اذا كان القوات الاوكرانيه تضع في
حساباتها عمليه الانسحاب من مدينه باغموت
واجابه ان الجيش الاوكراني والقياده
الاوكرانيه تضع في حساباتها هذا الخيار
واذا ما كان هنالك اي عمليه انسحاب من
مدينه فهي ستكون عمليه انسحاب استراتيجيه
وليست عمليه انسحاب عشوائيه وقال ايضا ان
الدفاعات الاستراتيجيه في غرب المدينه حيث
تسيطر القوات الاوكرانيه تم تجهيزها لهذا
الخيار لذلك هي تضع في حساباتها هذا الامر
ولكن في الوقت الحالي لم يتخذ القرار ولا
حاجه لذلك في الوقت الحالي والقوات
الاوكرانيه تسيطر بشكل كامل كما يقول
الاعلام الاوكراني انه تم تاويل ذلك من
قبل وكالات الانباء الروسيه وبعض وكالات
الانباء المحسوبه على روسيا وانتشر على
هذا الاساس هذا الامر عن ان ممكن ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ستنسحب من هذه المدينه
على العكس تماما طبعا بعد ذلك الرد
وافاد شريفاتي وهو الناطق باسم القوات في
الشرق وقال ان القوات الاوكرانيه تسيطر ما
زالت على المدينه ولا حاجه لاي عمليه
انسحاب من هذه المدينه وايضا تحدثت عن
طبيعه القوات التي تقاتل من قوات ووصفها
بانها اكثر الاكثر تدريبا
في موسكو اسالك كذلك تطور لافت اليوم جرى
الحديث عن طائرات مسيره
هاجمت شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا
ولكن ايضا الطائرات المسيره على ما يبدو
حلقت في وكذلك في العاصمه موسكو ما الذي
تقوله القوات الروسيه حول الهجوم المحتمل
بالمسيرات من قبل الاوكرانيين
اليوم الثاني موجه كبيره من
المسيرات الاوكرانيه كما قالت الدفاع
الروسيه اليوم صدت هجمات واسعه النطاق من
قبل المسيرات الاوكرانيه التي استهدفت شبه
جزيره القرم هناك نحو اسقطت نحو سته
مسيارات وقامت بتعطيل اربعه مسيرات
بالاضافه الى خمسه عشر مسيره ايضا استهدفت
الاقاليم الجديده التي ضمتها روسيا مؤخرا
بالاضافه الى يوم امس كان هناك استهداف
لخمس مناطق من بينهم منطقه هي قريبه من
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو كانت سقطت فيها
ايضا مسيره كانت تستهدف مواقع تابعه لشركه
غاسبروم ولكن حول طبعا التصريحات او ما
تناقلته وسائل الاعلام في بالنسبه لمدينه
بطرسبورغ الدفاع الروسيه اكدت انها قامت
باجراء مناورات في سماء مدينه بطرسبرج على
خلف على خلفيتها قامت باغلاق المجال الجوي
صهيب كاتيا وحذيفه ونحن نتحدث الان عاجل
الان يظهر على شاشه العربيه نق لا عن
الدفاع الاوكرانيه التي تؤكد ان روسيا
تواصل التقدم في محور باخمت حذيفه كنت
سالتك عن عن ذلك يبدو ان القوات
الاوكرانيه بالفعل تواجه ضغطا كبيرا من
القوات الروسيه خاصه من مجموعه التي تحاصر
ضخمه ولكن حدثني كذلك عن حرب المسيرات
التي ربما بداتها اوكرانيا
نعم في الحقيقه اوكرانيا افادت بشكل واضح
انها لا تنفذ اي ضربات داخل الاراضي
الروسيه هي ما زالت تقوم بكامل عملياتها
العسكريه والقتال داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
والهدف من ذلك استرداد الاراضي التي وصفها
ميخائيل بودلاك مستشار الرئيس المحتله من
قبل المحتلين وقال ان هدفنا هو استعاده
كامل اراضينا ولكنه ايضا قال ان هذا صراع
داخلي داخل الاتحاد الروسي وهذا ذعر داخلي
وهذا طبيعي نتيجه للوضع الذي وضع بوتين
فيه البلاد وستعاني روسيا من مثل هذه
الانقسامات التي سماها والتي يمكن ان تحدث
داخليا في الدوله الروسيه ايضا هنالك
تصريح اخر طبعا من قبل الاتحاد الروسي حول
ان اوكرانيا سوف تستخدم اسلحه اشعاعيه في
منطقه تراسلين سيريا وايضا النفط وزاره
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه وقالت ان هذه
الدعاءات مزيفه وان اوكرانيا متمسكه بعدم
انتشار الاسلحه الاشعاعيه والكيميائيه وان
في الغالب ما تقوم روسيا بالترويج له هذا
ما ستقوم به بنفسها يعني يتهمون ايضا
الرسل لانه سوف يقومون بهذه الاستفزازات
ويتهمون بها الجانب الاوكراني مراسله
العربيه من كييفوا موسكو حذيفه عادل
وتزول المشاهدين مع الحديث الاوكراني عن
تعزيزات الروسيه في البحر الاسود تتحضر
روسيا لضم غواصات النوويه جديده الى
اسطولها البحري مما يشكل تحديا دفاعيا
للولايات المتحده والنيتو وفقا نيويورك
اكبر شركه لبناء السفن في روسيا والمنتج
الوحيد في البلاد
للغواصات التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه
ستزود البحريه الروسيه اذا
بغواصتين جديدتين الامبراطور الكسندر
الثالث
هذه الغواصه ايضا الجديده كذلك في نهايه
العام الجاري غواصه الامبراطور الكسندر
الثالث مشاهدينا حظيت باهتمام الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين شخصيا العام الماضي
ورفع عليها العلم الروسي في التاسع
والعشرين من ديسمبر الفائت هذه الغواصه
النوويه مشاهدينا هي قادره على حمل 16
صاروخا باليستيان عابر للقارات وهي سابع
صواريخ من عائله ومن المقرر بدء التجارب
البحريه عليها في يونيو المقبل كجزء من
برنامج التسلح الحالي في روسيا لضمان امن
البلاد في السنوات القادمه وفقا لما اعلنه
الرئيس الروسي هذا فيما يتعلق بالغواصات
الروسيه اما على الجانب الاخر الجانب
الامريكي القوه البحريه الامريكيه
المتمثله باسطول اوهايو
فلديها اربعه عشره غواصه مشاهدينا ويشار
اليها باسم بومرز وكل غواصه نوويه من هذا
الاسطول تحمل ما يصل الى عشرين صاروخا
باليستيان برؤوس حربيه متعدده وموجهه بشكل
مستقل كما انها تمتلك ثلاثه فتحات ذات قطر
اكبر تسمح بالنقل السريع لمنصه الامداد
ووحدات استبدال المعدات ومكونات الالات
بما يسمح بوقت اقل عند التجديد والصيانه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مباشره الى مؤتمر صحفي لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
ان نتقبل تهديدات لشخصيات عامه وعلى ابناء
عائلاتهم
كما يحدث في هذه الاثناء
انا خلوني
لن نقبل
العنف لا في حواره
ولا في الشوارع ولا في اي مكان
لقد اعطيتهم اسئله
واريد ان اعطيكم الان مثلا
مخالفا كيف يجب ان يقول الاحتجاج
قبل 20 عاما
كان هناك نقاش لا يقل جدلا ولا يقول هزا
للمشاعر كان هناك
الكثير من المواطنين الذين عارضوا لسياسه
الحكومه
واحس بان عالمهم خرب
في قضيه فك الارتباط ولما لا مش منتبه
لا اكثر من 8000 اسرائيلي من بيوتهم
وان يخرج الناس الموتى من القبور
وتقلع
السوطنات
[موسيقى]
وهذا كان بالنسبه
الثالث
وخرجوا في مواجهه ونضال
قويا هذا هذا
[موسيقى]
النضال لم يشتد هذه الخطوط لم نرى اليوم
لم
يعتدي
المتظاهرون على الشرطه
ولم يخرج اموالهم من الدوله
ولم يحرضوا على اسرائيل في العالم
لا لم ندعو الى لم ندعو حينها الى رمز
الخدمه العسكريه او الى شل المرافق
الاقتصاديه
ولم نحاول ان نقود الدوله الى فوضى
المختصر
لم نجتز خطوط الحمراء
ولكن في تلك الفتره عندما كانت معارضه تحت
رئاسته
بمسؤوليه ولكن اليوم المعارضه تتصرف بدونه
المعارضه تقول وانا اقتبل
متى
رئيس حزب اخر يحرض على المظاهرات
الازمه الدستوريه الى انتخابات شديده
واقول شيئا اضافيا
اعرف انها ليس الجميع
في المعارضه
هناك من يعارض الخط المتطرف
ويحفظون من العمليات
الشعبويه
المنظمه ايضا من قبل
عوامل داخليه وخارجيه
الى هؤلاء الناس المسؤولين
اقول لكم شيئا اضافيا
اذا لم نقم بذلك
الوضع
الخطوط الحمراء
ستمحى في الاتجاه الاخرى
اريد ان ادعو الجميع
الى السماء
التي طردت
وقالت
ان اللحظه الاصعب في حياتي
مجددا الى تهدئه الخواطر ووقت العنف
باننا سنجد الطريق قريبا
للحوار وللاف والتفاهمات
نعتدل واحد على الاخر لا يوجد لنا دوله
اخرى
شكرا لكم
اذا مشاهدينا استمعنا لهذه الكلمه
لبنيامين نتناول رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
هو يتحدث عن الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل
والمظاهرات التي خرجت وتخرج منذ فتره
لمتظاهرين ضد ما يعرف باصلاح النظام
القضائي في اسرائيل وهو القانون المثير
للجدل اليوم الشرطه الاسرائيليه اشتركت مع
عدد من المتظاهرين نتنياهو قال ان
المعارضه الاسرائيليه تتصرف بدون مسؤوليه
وهي تحرض على التظاهر وقال المتظاهرون ضد
الاصلاح اعتدوا اصلاح القضاء اعتدوا اذا
على الشرطه وقال قبل ذلك بانه لا يقبل
بالعنف في اي مكان ان كان في حواره ولا في
اي مكان اخر
[موسيقى]
وافق البرلمان الفنلندي باغلبيه ساحقه على
مشروع قانونين بشان انضمام البلادي الى
صوت 184 نائبا لصالح الانضمام فيما صوت
سبعه برلمانيين ضده ويتطلب التصديق
النهائي على مشروع القانون موافقه الرئيس
عليه
وفي فنلندا ايضا والحمايه نفسها وتعزيز
امنها ضد اي محاولات لاختراق حدودها بدات
فلندا بناء سياج بطول 200 كيلومتر على
حدودها مع روسيا واعلن حرس الحدود
الفنلنديه عن ارتفاع السياج ان هذا السياج
سيصل ارتفاعه الى ثلاثه امتار وسيوضع فوقه
سلك شائك وتشترك في اللاندا مشاهدينا في
اطول حدود لدوله عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي
مع روسيا حيث يبلغ طول الحدود بينهما
1340 كيلومترا وحاليا يتم تامين حدود
فنلندا بشكل اساسي بواسطه اسوار خشبيه
خفيفه وجاء هذا القرار بسبب ارتفاع اعداد
الروس الذين يسعون للهروب من التجنيد
الاجباري للقتال في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمرا نتابع فيها بعد
فاصل
صوره حديثه للاقمار الصناعيه تكشف
استعدادات اثيوبيا للملء الرابع لسد
النهضه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شحنات يورانيوم روسيه
للصين تثير مخاوفا من سباق تسلح النووي
عالمي سيما مع تقارير تتحدث عن نوايا
صينيه لاستخدامها بمفاعل سي اف ار 600
وفقا لبلومبورج التي كشفت انه بين سبتمبر
وديسمبر استوردت بيكين من موسكو كميات
كبيره من اليورانيوم هذه الماده مشاهدينا
تستخدم لانتاج البلوتونيوم الذي يمكن
استخدامه بالاسلحه النوويه الامر الذي
اكدته الاستخبارات الامريكيه واعتبرت ان
اليورانيوم سيساعد بكين على زياده مخزون
الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه بنحو اربعه اضعاف
في السنوات المقبله مما يسمح للصين
بمضاهات الترزانه النوويه التي تنشرها
الولايات المتحده وروسيا حاليا ويسهم
بزعزعه التوازن العسكري في اسيا حيث
تتزايد التوترات بشان تايوان والسيطره على
بحر جنوب الصين يقول
التعاون مشاهدينا في مجال الدفاع
والتكنولوجيا له مكانه خاصه في العلاقات
وفق ما قاله رئيس فلاديمير بوتين لنظيره
الصينيشي اواخر ديسمبر العام الماضي هذا
الكلام اقلق واشنطن والامم المتحده
وتحديدا بعد ان توقفت الصين عن الابلاغ عن
مخزونات البلوتونيوم حيث تعمل بسريه تامه
مما اثار الشكوك الدوليه
[موسيقى]
بعد سنوات من قتال تنظيم داعش والتغلب
عليه تبقت معركه اخرى هي اكثر صعوبه وهي
مواجهه ارثه الفكريه المتطرف وبقايا
مقاتليه وافراد عائلاته التي تتوزع في
مخيمات وسجون داخل العراق وسوريا العربيه
وضمن الترقيتها الخاصه دخلت اخطر تلك
المخيمات وهو مخيم الهول الذي تقيم فيه
زوجات مقاتلي داعش وابنائهم من العرب
والاجانب والتقت بهم ورصدت الاوضاع
الامنيه فيه بعد اكتشاف نشاط واضح لخلايا
التنظيم بداخل المخيم
لن تبقى له حصون ولا مدن ولكن لا يعتقد
كثيرون هنا في شمال شرق سوريا ان تنظيم
داعش زال يقولون انه باق في مخيمات
والسجون وخلال نائمه ورحله البحث عنه لا
تبدا الا من مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
الدخول لمخيم رهول السدعه التنقل في مركبه
مصفحه وحراسه مسلحين من قوات حمايه المخيم
وهؤلاء لا ينتشرون عاده داخل المخيم بل
يكتفون بمراقبه البوابات وتسير دوريات لكن
جوله كهذه تثير مخاوفهم من هجوم مسلح او
حتى بحجاره
[موسيقى]
53 الف شخص من 56 دوله يقطنون هنا
ويتوزعون على سته اقسام غالبيتهم من عائله
الدواعش قدمنا من الباغوز ومناطق اخرى
بدانا جولتنا من قسم المهاجرات والاسم
الذي يطلق على قسم زوجات الدواعش غير
السوريه او العراقيات واطفالهن به خيام
وسوق للملابس والخضر
من اين انت
تتحدثين قليلا من العربيه
متى اتيت الى هذا المخيم
الاقتراب من اخريات كان اسهل لكن الحديث
معهن كان ينعطف سريعا الى السماته في
الدفاع عن التنظيم
[موسيقى]
اوامر من خليفه اجاعتنا امير وقال انتم
لازم اجباريات
مع اخوان مجاهدين ها انتم تطلعوا هناك ان
شاء الله
طبقتم شرع الله
[موسيقى]
لا ترغب ام محمد وهكذا تسمي نفسها بالعوده
الى مصر فهي تعتقد انما تسميها دوره
الخلافه ستعود ترغبين بالعوده الى مصر
لكن اخريات ربما يئسنا ويامن فقط بان
يعدنا لبلدانهن
ترغبين فعلا بالعوده للمغرب فعلا اكيد
اليوم قبل بكره
ندمتي على ذهابك
يعني لازم نحن نرجع بلدنا ما يضلوا
اوضاعنا هيك يعني في
المخيم يعني انت شوفي يعني معروف الخيام
والوسخ وكل شيء يعني لازم يعني
ترحيل عائله داعش وتفكيك المخيم مسعا عبرت
عنه قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه التي طالبت
مرارا دولا باستلام رعاياها من عائله
التنظيم برايي الشخص انه اكثر من خمس سنين
او ست سنين احنا بحاجه لهم لحتى نفكك مخيم
الهول بالكامل لانه العدد كثير كبير العدد
ضخم انت عم تحكي عن 53 الف لاجئ ونازح
عندك العراقيين ما يقارب 27 الف عراقي
والسوريين اللي موجودين هن نسبتهم اكثر من
18 الف سوري اغلبيتهم هنن من مناطق سيطره
الحكومه السوريه
وعندك قسم خاص بالاجانب اللي هنن
المهاجرات او اذا بدك تخلي المخيم منهم
هنبيعها بحاجه لقرارات دوليه صارمه حتى
انت تقدري تفكي المخيم وترجعي كل هدول
لبلدانهم
مهمه صعبه اذا فيما اداره المخيم وتامينه
يبدوان اصعب
[موسيقى]
كان في حمله امنيه للقوات حمايه المخيم
داخل المخيم خلال الحمد لله الامنيه تنضبط
كميه كبيره من الاسلحه كمان تم القبض على
كثير من خلايا داعش
خطر بدا اوضح بعد اكتشاف شبكه خنادق
وانفاق محفوره تحت الارض لتهريب السلاح
ومتطرفين وامواله صار بن عيشوبه العربيه
مخيم الهول في شمال شرق سوريا
معنى من تونس دكتور علي العلاني الباحث في
شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه الدكتور علي اهلا
بك معنا في اخبار التاسعه يعني 53 الف شخص
من عائلات داعش موجوده في هذا المخيم الى
اي حد هذا يشكل قنبله موقوته قد تنفجر في
ايه لحظه
مساء الخير تحيه لكم ولكل الساده
المشاهدين اعتقد ان هؤلاء بالفعل قنبله
موقوته
وخاصه لدولتين يعني لدوله سوريا والعراق
باعتبار ان مخيم الهول الذي يضم 53 الف
يعني من النساء واطفال داعش نجد ان منهم
خمسه واربعين الف ينتمون الى سوريا
والعراق اي
هناك ثمانيه الاف من الاجانب الاخرين من
مقسومين على حوالي 51 دوله وبالتالي الخطر
سيكون بطبيعه الحال شاملا
لكل المناطق التي
مع هذا الخطر خاصه انه استمعنا الى
الشهادات
هؤلاء النسوه لديهم اطفال لديهم اطفال
وهؤلاء الاطفال يسمونهم باشبال الخلافه
حسب تسميتهم هم يعني وهم يذكرونهم دائما
يغذونهم بنفس الفكر المتطرف لداعش ما نوع
الخطر او مشاكل الخطر الذي يمكن ان يشكله
هؤلاء الاطفال الصغار مستقبلا
يعني هو بالتاكيد خطر يعني ما حق باعتبار
انه لو عدنا الى تقارير الامم المتحده
عندما تتحدث عن دوافع يعني الانتماء الى
داعش نجد في هذه التقارير ان 60% من يعني
الاسباب هي تعود الى الهشاشه النفسيه هذا
بالنسبه للدواعش الذين قدموا من بلدانهم
فما بالك بالدواعش الذين عاشوا لسنوات في
هاته المخيمات التي لا يعني توجد فيها
ادنى الضروريات وبالتالي هؤلاء
في النهايه خاصه الاطفال اتحدث عن الاطفال
اتحدث هم اطفال ابرياء يعني
حكم عليهم حكمت عليهم الظروف ان يولدوا في
هذه الظروف برايك ما هي المقاربه الانجع
للتعامل مع موضوع اسر داعش واطفال داعش
الذين يسمونهم باشبال الخلافه خاصه انه
الدول الاوروبيه مثلا رفضت استقبال عدد
كبير من رعايا هناك عدد قليل فقط من هذه
العائلات من تمكن من العوده الى اوروبا
فما هي المقاربه الانجع برايك للتعامل مع
هذا الملف
اعتقد ان المقاربه الان هي ستكون مقاربه
نفسيه اجتماعيه ماديه باعتبار ان هؤلاء
الاطفال ليس لهم ذنب يعني انهم جاؤوا من
ابناء دواعش وبالتالي نرى ان هذه
المسؤوليه لا تعود فقط الى البلدان التي
يعني يطلب من منها ان تستعيد يعني الاطفال
وزوجات هؤلاء الدواعش المساله اكبر من ذلك
بما ان هناك 53 دوله لها عناصر داعشيه
سواء كانوا صغارا عن اطفالا او نساء من
يعني فيه في مخيم الهول فقط ولا نتحدث عن
المخيمات الاخرى اذا فالمقاربه هي ان هذا
الموضوع اصبح موضوعا دوليا ما دام هناك 53
دوله يعني ان الامم المتحده يجب ان تاخذ
على عاتقها الاعداد المادي وتخصيص ام هامه
لكي يتم تاهيل هؤلاء الاطفال وايضا
معالجتهم نفسيا
وتمكينهم او ما يسمى بادماجهم في المجتمع
عبر يعني يعني وسائل
التدريس ويعني الافكار او الافكار المضاده
لما تعلموه في تلك المخيمات اذا هذا لا
تقدر عليه دوله بمفردها يجب ان تنتظم
مؤتمرات دوليه تشرف عليها المتحده وتخصص
لها مثل ما تخصص للكوارث الطبيعيه هذه
كوارث انسانيه يمكن ان تحدث يعني فوضى
وعدم استقرار في العديد المدني اذا تلك
المؤتمرات الدوليه تضبط فيها طريقه تاهيل
وادماج هؤلاء وهذا يستوجب ميزانيات هامه
وعلى الجميع يعني جميع الدول وخاصه الامم
المتحده ان تقوم بواجبها
يعني تفكيك تلك المخيمات التي يجب ان لا
تستمر الى ما لا نهايه له دكتور علي
العلانيه الباحث في شؤون الجماعات
المتطرفه شكرا جزيلا لك من تونس
[موسيقى]
قلل المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
تدرس خلال زيارته الى شمال غرب سوريا ان
الاوضاع الانسانيه صعبه في المنطقه التي
ضربها الزلزال مضيفا ان هناك حاجه لمزيد
من الاموال للتخفيف من وطئه معاناه
المتضررين
من الصعب نقل عمق معاناه الشعب السوري لقد
كنت بالفعل منزعجا للغايه وحزينا تسببت
زلزال الذي ضرب منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اسابيع
في ماساه لا يمكن تصورها للاشخاص الذين
عانوا بالفعل اكثر من 12 عاما من الحرب
والانهيار الاقتصادي وهو باقي كورونا
وتفشي الكوليرا المستمر اقدم التعازيه
لاولئك الذين فقدوا احبائهم
في اثيوبيا كشفت صوره حديثه التقطتها
الاقمار الصناعيه استعدادات للملا الرابع
لسد النهضه كما توضح الصوره افتتاح
اثيوبيا قبل يومين البوابه الغربيه للسد
وتركت البوابه الشرقيه لتصريف حوالي 50
مليون متر مكعب من المياه
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير خالد بن
سلمان اليوم انه وقع مع نظره البريطاني
بين ولاس اعلان نوايا بشان مشاركه المملكه
في برنامج القدرات الجويه المستقبليه
واضاف الامير خالد عبر حسابه على تويتر ان
البرنامج سيسهم في تعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه
للمملكه وتطوير المنظومات الجويه
المستقبليه واشار وزير الدفاع السعوديه
الى انه بحث مع نظيره البريطانيه التعاون
في المجال العسكري والدفاعي وسبل تعزيزه
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد فاصل
بامر ملكي جديد تجريده الامير هاري وزوجته
ميجان من منزلهما في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد قال الرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد ان من تامروا على امن الدوله
الداخليه والخارجي لا يمكن ان يلعبوا دور
الضحيه وخلال لقائه بوزيره العدل اشار
سعيد الى ان الضحيه هو الشعب في قوته
وصحته
ومعاشه مؤكدا ان من حقه اي حاسبه في اطار
القانون كل من تامر على حقوقه وياتي ذلك
في ظل ملاحقه قضائيه لنحو 20 شخصا من
سياسيين واعلاميين ورجال اعمال بسبب
اتهامات تتعلق بالتامر على الدوله
[موسيقى]
شادينا نذهب الان الى ايران قضيه تسميمه
طالبات المدارس هناك تتفاقم واكثر من الف
طالبه تسممت بغاز ان تو والسلطات
الايرانيه حتى اللحظه لم تعلن اعتقال اي
احد على خلفيه هذه الحوادث حوادث التصميم
نشطؤوا ايرانيون يؤكدون انها متعمده وتاتي
في اطار خلق ازمه المجتمعيه لتفقد قضيه
الاحتجاجات زخمها وحرف الانتباه عن
الاحتجاجات الحاصله ضد النظام الايراني
منذ سبتمبر واليوم ايضا مشاهدينا شهدت
مدرسه في العاصمه طهران تسمما جديدا
واولياء الامور يؤكدون اطلاق نوع من
الرذاذ في المدرسه على بناتهم هجمات السم
هذه تشمل حتى اليوم نحو خمس مدن على الاقل
في ايران مستهدفه اكثر من 30 مدرسه مما
دفع الاباء لاخراج بناتهم من المدارس حيث
بلغ تصميم وطالبات المدارس في ايران شهره
الخامس والتي بدات حالته بالظهور في شهر
نوفمبر الماضي بمدينه قم اي بعد شهر من
الاحتجاجات على النظام وزارته الصحه
الايرانيه قالت ان السمة خفيف مشدده على
ان التحقيق فيما حدث للفتيات من تسمم ليس
من اختصاصها بل وانها ليست مسؤوله عن
الادلاء بتصريحات حول ما اذا كان الحادث
متعمدا ام اما مسؤولوه النظام فاتهموا من
قالوا انه عدو خارجيه يتدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه
وتحرك مندسيها هناك وفقه وصفهم ايرانيون
معارضون مشاهدينا يرون ان ما يحدث هو
تقليد ممنهج لسلوك بوكو حرام في نيجيريا
وطالبان في افغانستان من ترويع للاهالي
للتوقف عن ارسال بناتهم الى المدرسه
[موسيقى]
نتابع منا اصله عبر سكايب مع عمار تسائي
عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان الاحوزيه سيد عمار
اهلا بك معنا في اخبار التاسعه من العربيه
من يقف وراء تسميم التلميذات في المدارس
الايرانيه
الكرام بطبيعه الحال لم توجد هناك انباء
مؤكده ولكن هناك تكهنات بان النظام هو
نفسه او اجهزته الامنيه هي التي تكمن وراء
هاي حالات هذه حالات التسمم او لنقل
مجموعه متطرفه داخل النظام الايراني هي
التي تقوم بهذه الحالات انتقاما من
عمار يعني هل هناك ادله على ذلك واذا ما
صح هذا الاتهام انه النظام الايراني مسؤول
عن عمليه تصميم الفتيات لاي هدف لماذا
يفعل ذلك
في البدايه هل هناك دليل نعم هناك دليل
لان النظام عاده ما ينتقم من الشعب عندما
تحدث ثوره او تحدث انتفاضه مثلا في
انتفاضه عندما خرج العرب الاحوازيين في
خرج العرب الحوازيون في انتفاضه كبيره في
الاحواز بعدها نشر النظام شبكات الماليه
واخذ واخذ الاموال الناس بواسطه اشخاص
كثيرين ومن ثم قام بمصادره هذه
الاموال انتقاما من العرب الذين شاركوا في
هذه الانتفاضه واعتمد الان ايضا النظام
يريد
الاهالي يبقون بناتهم في البيوت ولا يخرج
من خشيه التسمم وخشيه القضايا الاخرى كما
انه يريد ان ينتقم من مشاركه الفتاه
والطالبات المدارس والجامعات من المشاركه
في الثوره التي انطلقت قبل خمسه شهور وهذا
احتمال وارد جدا وكما تعرفون ان النظام
الايراني هو يعادي يعادي
الفتاه ويعادي البنات نقطه اخرى تبدو
غامضه اطلب من حضرتك ان تفسرها لنا اول
عمليه تسميم للفتيات في المدارس حصلت في
قم هل لي هذا اي تفسير اي اي دلاله
ربما ربما هي قوم مدينه دينيه ويتواجد
فيها الكثير من رجال الدين والجو العام
فيها هو جو عام تسيطر عليه وتهيمن عليه
الحوزه العلميه والنظام الايراني وهو موطن
النظام الايراني ومركز انتشار التشيع مركز
انتشار النظام
الايراني فاعتقد ان الاجواء الدينيه
والتطرف الموجود لدى بعض رجال الدين هناك
الموالين للنظام هو السبب الحقيقي والسبب
الاصلي وراء وراء ظهور هذه الظاهره في هذه
المدينه شكرا جزيلا لك عمرت سائى انت عضو
منظمه حقوق الانسان الاحوازيه كنت معنا من
اوسلو
ني المتحده
في اعاده العمل بالاتفاق النوويه الايراني
مره اخرى وجاء ذلك خلال مؤتمر صحفي في
ختام زيارته الى بغداد
مستحيل ان اتي الى العراق ولا اناقش
العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده وايران
ولذلك فانه من الواضح انني ناقشت هذه
المساله ولكن هذه القضيه لا يمكن حلها بين
الامم المتحده والعراق اود التاكيد على
دعم القوي لخطه العمل المشتركه واؤمن ان
الاتفاق النووي احد اهم الانتصارات
السياسيه في الوقت الراهن واعمل ان نتغلب
على الصعوبات في تنفيذه
ولاول مره السفن الحربيه تتابعه للوصول
السادس والثمانين التابعي للبحريه
الايرانيه في القاره الامريكيه هذا وفقا
لما افادت به وكاله تسنيم التي كشفت ان
السفن الحربيه مرت من قناه بنما ورست في
ميناء في اول رحله حول العالم في تاريخ
الاصول الايراني واكدت الوكاله الايرانيه
انه من بين هذه السفن توجد حامله
المروحيات مكرم والمدمره دانه
[موسيقى]
موضوع كورونا يعود مره اخرى البحث عن اصل
منشا فيروس تسعه عشر مثاروا جدلا بين
الولايات المتحده والصين تصريحات صادره عن
مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكيه
قال فيها ان اصول الجائحه على الارجح حادث
مختبري محتمل فيوهان رددت عليها الصين
بالرفض داعيه واشنطن الى عدم التلاعب
بالموضوع سياسيا
اين نشا فيروس كورونا وكيف سؤال تحولت
الاجابه عنه الى جبهه تصريحات مفتوحه
ومتبادله بين الولايات المتحده والصين
واشنطن انحت باللائمه على بخصوص مسؤوليه
انتشار الوباء الذي اوقف عجله العالم عن
الدوران وغير الكثير من القواعد فالجائحه
نتيجه لحادث مختبري في مدينه ووهان
الصينيه وفق مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
الامريكي
لقد قيم مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الان
ان اصول الجائحه هي على الارجح حادث
مختبري محتمل في ووهان كلام اغضب السلطات
الصينيه كثيرا فحسب بكين الولايات المتحده
تتلاعب سياسيا في قضيه اصل فيروس كورونا
الخارجيه الصينيه دعت واشنطن الى احترام
العلوم والحقائق
تعرض الصين بشده اي شكل من اشكال التلاعب
السي في مساله تعقب اصول فيروس كورونا نحث
الجانب الامريكي الاحترام العلم والحقائق
والتوقف عن تسييس قضيه تتبع فيروس كوفيد
تصريحات الجانبين جاءت في اعقاب تقرير
نشرته صحيفه
ليس مبنيا على قدر كبير من الثقه لوزاره
الطاقه الاميركيه قال ان الوباء نتج عن
تسريب غير مقصود من مختبر صيني لتستمر
حكايه اصل الوباء مصدر اتهامات متبادله
بين الشرق والغرب بلال الوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت مجموعه ام بي سي بان مسلسل معاويه
ما زال قيد التحضير واكدت ان موعد عرضه
سيتم تحديده لاحقا ونفت ام بي سي صدور اي
بيانات او كتب رسميه عنها وشددت المجموعه
على ان البيانات المتعلقه بمجموعتها تصدر
رسميا عنها وتوزع عبر مكتبها الاعلامي من
مقرها الرئيسي وان المصدر الوحيد الموثوق
للمعلومات المتعلقه بانتاجاتها وعروضها
وجدولها هو الشاشات ومنصاتها وصفحاتها
الرسميه فقط
[موسيقى]
في تفاعل قضيه تيك توك وحظره من قبل دول
غربيه اقرت لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس
النواب الامريكيه مشروع قانوننا يمنح رئيس
جو بايدن الحق في حظر منصه مقاطع الفيديو
القصيره تيك توك وصوتت لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه على منح بايدن سلطه حظر التطبيق
المملوك للصين والتطبيقات اخرى بغلبيه 24
صوتا مقابل 16 وكانت الحكومه الامريكيه
امرت بازاله التطبيق على الاجهزه
الفيدراليه في غضون 30 يوما
من جانبها تهمه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه التي حاده الاوروبي باساءه
استخدام مفهوم الامن القومي عقب اعلان
البرلمان الاوروبيه انه سيحضر تطبيق الصين
لمشاركه الفيديو تيك توك من اجهزه
الموظفين وطالبت المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
لاتحاد الاوروبي باحترامي مبدا المنافسه
العادله للشركات العامله في السوق
الاوروبيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي انه سوق الاكثر انفتاحا
في العالم لكنه اتخذ مؤخرا تدابير مقيده
بشكل غير معقول تجاه شركات البلدان الاخرى
على اساس الامن القومي هذا من شانه اضعاف
ثقه المجتمع الدولي في بيئه الاعمال في
الاتحاد الاوروبي يجب على الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان يربط اقواله بالافعال وان
يحترم اقتصاد السوق والمنافسه العادله وان
يقف عن اساءه استخدام مفهوم الامن القومي
وفيما يخص تيك توك ايضا يعتزم تطبيق
الفيديوهات القصيره الذي يواجه انتقادات
على خلفيه خطر تسببه بالادمان لدى
اليافعين وحتى الكبار ايضا يعتزم اعتماد
اليه تحذير للمستخدمين بعد مرور 60 دقيقه
على بدء الاستخدام لما يبلغ 18 عاما واكثر
وذلك خلال الاسابيع المقبله وسيتعين على
مستخدمي تيك توك ادخال كلمه سر لمواصله
تصفح الموقع والذي اتاح ايضا امكانيه
تحديد كلمه السر من الوالدين
[موسيقى]
بامر ملكي عقاب اخر على الامير هاري
وزوجته ميجا ماركل اللذان يفقدان المنزل
الذي اعتاداه السكن فيه وهما في بريطانيا
اذا عرضه الملك تشارلز على اخيها الامير
اندرو للسكنى قالت ان قرار الملك تشارلز
الثالث ياتي في اعقاب التصريحات المسيئه
لهاري وميجانس وافراد الاخرين من العائله
المالكه في مذكراته الاخيره وورد في
الصحيفه ان منزلهما السابق وهو فروجومور
كوتيج عرض على الامير اندرو وهو الشقيق
شقيق الملك الاصغر الذي اجبر على التخلي
عن دوره الملكي لكن اندرو بدوره رفض هذا
العرض
التاسع انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز عناوينها
لتحقيق نصر غائب منذ سته اشهر روسيا تضيق
الخناقه على باخموت وكيف ترد باستهداف
القرم بالمسيرات
جيل جديد باعداد كبيره ينشا في خيم
الدواعش في الهول في جوله حصريه كما
العربيه في مخيم الهول وهناك ارث داعش
العائلي والفكريه تنامى عبر اشبال التنظيم
في ايران تجدد ظاهره التسميم العمد
لطالبات المدارس والسلطات تلقي باللوم على
عدو خارجي المجهود
الضغوط الامريكيه على تيك توك تزداد مجلس
النواب يمنح الرئيس بايدن الحق في حظر
التطبيق الصينيه
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت شكرا لكم على كرم
المشاهده اعود والقاكم في اخبار الساعه
عند الثامنه بتوقيت اما الان فاترككم مع
الزميل طاهر بركه اذا والعربيه 300
اذا اليك يا طاهر ماذا لديك يبدو ان لديك
مؤشرات على حرب محتمله بين امريكا وايران
في اول عنوان تمام العنوان الاول تقارير
عن تجهيز الفانتاجون خطه طوارئ لحرب مع
ايران وسنركز على هذا الموضوع اضافه الى
ضخموت بطبيعه الحال ومخيم ابو الهول
والدويل التي تقام هناك اضافه الى موعد
الانتخابات التركيه وجديد ذلك على اثر
الزلزال كن معنا سنكون معك يا طاهر شكرا